blade smith congratulations you made it
through a really brutal round of testing
and now here you are
that much closer to being forced in fire
champions well now we're sending you
back to your home for just to recreate
this iconic weapon you ready to see what
it is
oh yeah
the nine ring broadsword
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days thank you good luck
[Music]
it's day one here at the home forge i
don't really have much experience making
something this big or this
wide playing for today is i got to get
the end of the sword drawn out quite a
ways i'm going to use 1080 steel nice
big heavy bar of it 1080. nice hard
steel that's forgiving a heat treatment
and an open forge
letters start warming up i'm doing
mostly work on the press
my plan is just to kind of get it worked
out a little bit here
just trying to break that down and
spread it out
peter back up has to be a minimum of two
and a half four inches from the tip so
i'm gonna go for three that way i got a
little bit of movement to do any tweaks
i need to after heat treat
i'm halfway there maybe
yeah
tip's coming right in there now starting
to take shape of us hard that's it for
day one
we are my home forge
i start forging the blade today and i'm
looking to have it fully forged
hopefully midday tomorrow to where i can
start doing some grinding
my biggest concern with this blade is
heat treat i really really hate to have
to start over again the end of the day
too
i've got a lot of meat in this thing
that needs to be thinned out fortunately
i have a power hammer that's going to
help a lot with making that happen oh
you've got to be kidding me
all of a sudden my power hammer decides
it doesn't want to play anymore it stops
working that sucks
so in between heats now i'm trying to
rewire my power hammer all right well
that ain't working finally get the
switch back together
so i'm working on the blade and drawing
it out and i notice there's a crack in
the blade
and there's no saving this
yeah that's junk
so on my backup steel's 0.1
it is a tool steel but it's not a good
steel for swords hopefully i can temper
it right and it'll still hold together
through the testing
it's day two for me today i'm gonna go
ahead and take some of this 3 16 rod and
a little scrolling jig and try to set up
some like inch and a half rings i'm
going to cut them off one at a time once
they get attached on the sword then i'll
probably just give them a little tig
weld to hold them together on there
getting ready to try to drill the holes
for the rings could have possibly got
too hard and the forging find out here
in a second
looks like it's drilling like butter
first two holes drilled just fine
that's harder
uh i was hoping they would drill easy
that's what i was afraid of it can be a
nine ring sword without nine holes for
the rings to go in feeling the clock now
that's not soft i'm gonna heat the spine
of it up with the torch and try to just
draw it back and hopefully it'll be soft
enough that i can get those lights out
holes punch through it if this doesn't
work i'm screwed
i'd hate to start forging again
still a heck of a lot of work to do so
it's critical that i really hit the heat
treat tonight
if it breaks if it cracks if it does
anything other than quenches hard and
straight i'm done
i have no backups anymore
we've got a hard blade it's straight
so as i start profiling the blade more
all of a sudden i noticed something's
gone wrong again
got a crack in the blade
i have no more steel to work with all
right so how do i fix that
i decided to just put scallops in
between all of the eyelets for the rings
and hopefully grind far enough down to
where i'm beyond where the crack is
no more crack doesn't look like the
picture but kind of like it tell you
true
[Music]
got some sweet tay
day four finally punched through the
last hole so now we got a nine whole
broad sword got the sword quenched
yesterday but i'm still under the gun
time to get all these rings welded on
here that's right
they're on there i'm gonna use a camo
colored paracord to do the wrap and it
gives enough grip and thickness to the
handle
thing's beastly
[Music]
i'm finished it's sharp it's an
instrument of death it's a wild thing
everything looks wicked
first thing i'm getting after is the
rings i'm going with eighth inch mild
steel i created a jig a while back for
bidding this kind of stuff you know
gonna put it in the jig bend them around
until they're pretty symmetrical and
pretty even
and not too bad so all i have left to do
is
get these rings welded in place
boy that looks like
it just doesn't want to weld together
very well i mean it starts to melt it
starts to do other things damn it but
finally blade's finished nine ring
broadsword brother
i'd love this thing i'd like to keep it
put on my wall but
i'd rather have 10 grand
basements
you have a gratitude
[Music]
gentlemen
your swords look magnificent
but are they deadly
to find that out we will take your
swords and deliver some killing blows on
this pig
carcass it's all about the kill in this
particular test britain you are first
are you ready sir yes sir
let's do this
pretty much what could go wrong as the
blade breaks or it's not sharp enough to
cut what it's supposed to cut and see
how it holds up
two
oh
no they're one
[Music]
all right burton first stop
what i love about this blade was the
balance the way i was able to move with
the blade everywhere
now let's talk about the breakage
okay
so the break happened right there where
the ring was attached
you can see it's really not a bad poor
scratcher you have there it could be
finer but rings when you're digging into
that could cause stress risers and it
broke right there where the ring was
well gentlemen the fight's not over
because mike your blade still has to
survive nine strikes on its kill test
target good luck gentlemen doug
[Music]
burton's blade broke right at one of the
holes i have them same holes in there
plus on my spine i've already had two
cracks
i'm terrified it's gonna break oh
the heart's starting to flutter a little
bit
[Applause]
[Music]
good job bro
burton unfortunately your blade broke
and can no longer continue with testing
and for that reason i have to dismiss
you from the forge
dude good job brother my brother sucks
dude man gorgeous weapon no thank you
seeing my blade break uh it's a
disappointment you know when you make it
to round three you want to win
you know the nine holes burnt through
four drill bits doing them so somewhere
through there i probably was given a
little too much pressure and caused the
stress riser to run down that blade that
was enough to cause a critical failure
in that blade i'm still proud of myself
with what i've done you know it was way
out of my wheelhouse
uh what's next for me is not swords
especially any nine ring swords that's
for damn sure
mike congratulations the strength and
integrity of your blade has made you a
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother
i have unfortunate fire holy crap man
come on forward and shake our hands
thank you thank you
good job thank you cause some of the
things that went wrong in my home forge
i was really sure that blade was gonna
break on me yeah
it's a happy night
[Music]
you